here's Game seven tonight Tom Verducci
part of that also at Sports Illustrated
in MLB Network back here on the show
it's awesome Tom this has been
incredible what's it been like from your
seat a thrilling I mean really that's
what comes to mind the fact that you
know we've had all kinds of games
probably the craziest game ever in the
series and Game five had some well
coached games but the fact is you look
at the course of this series fifty seven
innings we've seen at the end of 50 for
them they've been separated by no more
than three runs it's incredible so what
does that mean it means really every
pitch it sounds like a cliche but in
this case it's literally true there were
every pitch something riding on it and
that that to me has been exhausting and
thrilling well let's get let's let's
let's dive a little bit deeper into this
before we get into tonight's game and
what we've already seen Tom because last
year I think if I asked you in a private
moment same with Joe Fox executives how
much but how could it get better than
the Cubs breaking their jinx and and
then against an Indians team that was
trying to do the same in a seventh game
that went to extra innings with the rain
delay and all that stuff and and home
runs by both teams right how could it
get any better and then this one it
feels like it's topping it it really
does there's no question about it
and I'm wondering why why do you think
this series has been so entertaining and
so good well I think it's the kind of a
series that appeals to a casual baseball
fan I wouldn't play it the classic kind
of series but what we're seeing here is
a lot of home runs a lot of back and
forth a lot of emotions especially on
the Astro side we you've seen a lot the
Dodgers as well so I think for a fan who
doesn't have rooting interest in the
game you're kind of locked in you know
you you know fall into this wave and
you're just wives riding it whereas last
year the narrative before the series
started already had people walked in you
know kind of Cubs when can the Indians
win and the history of those narratives
I think carried everybody through the
games were great Game seven was
fantastic but in this case I think there
wasn't you know obviously the Astros
don't have a national profile the Cubs
had they haven't won in their history
you have the Dodgers have won since 88
but the games themselves have told
people and if I'm correct I think the
ratings for the
Cirie's have gone up with every
successive game that doesn't happen all
the time and that tells you people are
getting on board because the baseball
team plays yeah and so what about the
baseball itself you're reporting on this
has been stellar in its own right I love
that article that you wrote where you
had Brett Strom the the the pitching
coach the Astra's hold a baseball from
the regular season in the World Series
in your hand our our audio executive as
he likes to be known here Mike Dell to
felt caught a foul ball in Game two of
the World Series he brought in and I
felt it felt like a cue ball Tom so what
what do you think that has had anything
to do with this World Series there's no
doubt it's had a big effect on the World
Series I mean garbage pitching tonight
for the Dodgers the last time he started
of course he was out before the second
inning ended did not get a single swing
and miss on his slider for the first
time and it's cool
first time this year you saw the way
cursor I got only one swing and Miss had
no slider whatsoever
Verlander last night kind of went away
with side in fact the ball he hit Chase
Utley with he said he really overcooked
it he yanked it because he's afraid of
hanging his slider which he did Peterson
in in Game two he did the Seager who
almost hit it out last night so it's had
an effect on the game I could tell you
this but Darvish in his bullpen session
before this game tonight made sure he
warmed up had a session with the World
Series ball because it's so different
fellas we know to the last two years and
two months that the baseball is livelier
it's flying out of the park it's a
homerun series it's been a home run year
but I think the fact that these
baseball's have been slick and you can
ask virtually every pitcher he's
pitching the series will tell you the
same thing
I think it's added to the fact that you
know it's tough to pitch with this
baseball in this environment I imagine
tonight we'll see more home runs even in
Game seven so how does something like
this happen Tom a great question I don't
think anything has been done deviously
with the face ball as far as the World
Series the slickness to the ball I've
talked to some people and they'll be and
they're confused I mean you have to at
least respect the opinion of these
professional pitchers who have a
baseball in their hand
all the time and they can put them
behind their back of regular season ball
and World Series ball and tell you which
is which without looking at them so
something's up
generally these balls get made in
batches and and the World Series ball
could be made in a batch you know months
ago you know even before the season you
know just because they're using the
matter that mean they were made last
week so was there something about the
batch of baseball when it was made was
it something about how the baseball's
were stored was there something about
the way the balls were rubbed up at the
mud I don't know the answer and I don't
think anybody got there in a lab and
said haha let's make a false liquor but
I think the pitchers and I've heard many
of them tell me this they want to know
why because they can't figure out Tom
Verducci of he'll be on tonight's Fox
broadcast and also and MLB Network in
si.com joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show all right so I'm assuming
everybody's up tonight
does that include even maybe Verlander
Tom well no I just and I'm sure a good
AJ and say hey I'm gonna have my spikes
on go to the bullpen I can get somebody
out I don't think AJ Hinch is gonna use
him I think that's probably too big a
task you know his heart would be in it
but really as a manager you have to say
what am i truly getting Justin Verlander
on note days of rest but yeah I think
everybody else is available here the
interesting thing to me in this game
tonight rich and certainly you're gonna
see it's employment cursor on Keuchel
you know from both sides get in this
game that this game go through Clayton
Kershaw and given the trouble he had you
know in the game in Houston where he had
a full run in the three-run lead back to
back getting lost them both you know how
much of this game will be dependent on
what he does and when do you use him
does he set up Kenley Jansen do you hold
him back in case you get kindling in
early again in the eighth and a neat
Kershaw behind him the way it happened
in the NLDS last year in Washington I'm
Clayton close that one out I just got a
feeling he is going to be a major player
in this game and when Dave Roberts
chooses to push that button will be
really fascinating well the best part
about that too for the Dodgers
perspective is Janssen only pitched 19
pitches in Game seven he really mode him
down he was great you know a little bit
like Mariano with that cutter but also
because of his efficiency he doesn't
walk people who walk seven batters the
entire season he goes right after people
you know he said that to the game last
night I'm good for nine and somebody
said when he talked about outs or inning
he said whatever I'm ready
I wouldn't wouldn't be shocked if the
Dodgers have a lead and he does get the
ball to start the evening well if that
happens you know okay at some point
Altuve step into the plate that guy is
unbelievable I I even asked Russell
Wilson about him yesterday when I had
Russell on the show just cuz I wanted to
get his perspective on somebody who is
so dynamic and so doesn't look the part
of a big burly MVP right I mean he's
unbelievable it's spring or in Bergman
and all of these kids I think that's
another reason why this series has been
so terrific is it young names that are
coming to the fore and killing it
in the stone about that I mean I think
people dig that when they're discovering
these young players some of them on the
big stage for the first time I me get
cleanup hitter for the Dodgers it's 22
the cleanup hitter for the Astros is 23
you're looking at Alex Bregman who I you
know I can't take my eyes off of his
at-bats you know he struck out only once
this postseason and everything is a war
with him between him the pitcher
you mentioned out Tuesday he may be one
of my favorite players to watch play
whether he's on the bases on defense at
bat you can see you're getting maximum
effort I love with the hitting coach by
the way Dave Hudgens said about Altuve
it looks sometimes like he can will
himself to get a hit I mean you can see
the persistence in his eyes and his body
language now the Dodgers have pitched
them great it kind of shackled him at
least in the games here at Dodger
Stadium so I think for the Astros to win
they do need their MVP to get something
going I really think because of his
energy they follow his feet a lot the
Dodgers a nice job kind of keeping them
down here at Dodger Stadium alright
before we send Tom off to work Brockman
asking the poll question here on today's
app Apple App Store Google Play hit the
Rich Eisen show
on the Twitter handle to get it to vote
on the question all right Tom what style
of game do you want to see tonight in
game seven pitcher's duel like Game six
shootout like Game five I want to see a
shootout and I would call it a manager's
game that's what I love about Game seven
right Game five was an unbelievable
players game offensive game at last
night more of a pitching game this game
is gonna be manager there's a second
guest City for everybody with so many
pictures available all the rules of
engagement go out the window in Game six
so when to use people when the poll
people want to bunt like all this stuff
oh it's great
nothing better I think there's nothing
better in sports than a game seven
I mean we played about 2,500 baseball
games this year in the major leagues and
you got one left that's it everything on
one game enjoy it Tom again you've been
awesome everybody on Fox the crews been
great the shots the slow-mo shots the
replays have been awesome and you've
been part of it thanks for calling in
Tom will chat soon
thanks you got it Tom Verducci for more
Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
channel 239 or DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up